le tribunal d'evry juge irrecevables les
demandes de la franco vietnamienne
contre 14 multinationales dans l'
affaire dite de l'agent orange un
défoliant toxique qui a déversé par
l'armée américaine lors de la guerre du
vietnam plus de précisions sur place
avec katia pique-niques
le tribunal a donné raison donc aux
quatorze sociétés à l'avocat du groupe
monsanto jean-daniel breitner il avait
tangué du fait qu'un tribunal français
n'était pas compétent pour juger
l'action d'un état étranger souverain
dans le cadre d'une politique de défense
en temps de guerre c'est à dire que les
juges français
pour les juges français les sociétés ont
agi durant la guerre du vietnam sur
ordre et pour le compte de l'état
américain dont l'accomplissement d'un
acte de souveraineté traînent tonia la
plaignante est âgé aujourd'hui de 79 ans
elle était résistant durant la guerre du
vietnam et elles étaient exposés à
l'agent orange un produit extrêmement
toxique à base de dioxyde plus de 80
millions de litres de ce produit ont été
pulvérisés durant la guerre du vietnam
et environ 4 millions de vietnamiens ont
été exposés cela a produit de nombreuses
maladies malformations chez des dizaines
de milliers de vietnamiens mais n'ont
jamais été indemnisés au contraire de
quelques vétérans américains qui ont
trouvé un accord avec monsanto dans les
années 80 180 millions de dollars
méteren tonia elle a voulu porter
plainte de porter l affaire devant les
tribunaux à cause des dommages pour sa
santé et le procès s'était enfin tenu
après six ans de procédure et 19 report
car depuis 2013 en fait une victime
française peut poursuivre un tiers
étranger pour un crime de guerre un
génocide ou un crime contre l'humanité
commis hors de france c'est pour cela
que 30 tonia espérer créer une
jurisprudence pour les nombreuses
victimes de pesticides ou d'armes
chimiques à travers le monde
alors demain la militante française
prendra la parole avec ses avocats
il faut savoir également que la marche
mondiale contre monsanto prendra place
pour sa neuvième édition le 15 mai
prochain